hello everyone and welcome to the most
requested game or rather a chess match
or a chess boxing match from yesterday's
Mogul chess boxing event that Ludwig
organized it was a spectacular event uh
uh so so well done uh with excellent
support for chess boards it was uh much
much better than I thought it could
possibly be done uh and with support for
multiple languages just a huge
congratulations to a lot because for
pulling off such a such an event and
this is one of the gates that you guys
requested the most it is Andrea botes
versus Dina bellancaya uh one of the I
believe there were 10 matches and um
well it's chess boxing for those of you
who don't know the rules of Chess boxing
first um uh you play chess there's a two
minutes of Chess and then there is 90
seconds or a minute and a half of uh of
boxing then we return two minutes of
Chess
um uh a minute and a half of boxing then
two minutes of just a minute and a half
of boxing so it's basically uh it's a
Blitz game both players have five
minutes on the clock but soon as those
two minutes of Chess
are depleted then the the boxing starts
and it's uh I I've seen some chess
boxing
um uh matches but not not in quite a
while so uh I didn't know what to expect
from this and this was uh this was such
a thriller if you guys have um if you
have the time to check out the original
video on loudly's channel uh you can
watch the entire stream but it's some
five and five hours or you can just
watch the separate matches I think he
uploaded them separately so you guys can
watch uh it's uh really really
impressive so this is one of the games
I'm going to show you uh and here uh
just before we we check out the game
here we have Andrea being brought in in
into the ring by his her sister
Alexandra it was a very very uh cheerful
it was uh you know sort of they said it
was a very Canadian style and here we
have Dina going into the the ring uh
accompanied by some Faceless Men here it
was not as cheerful but also
you know quite nice here you have the
stats between them you can see that
they're of the same height the weight is
almost the same Dina has a bit of a bit
of a a longer reach although not not
that important I I I I don't really
follow boxing so I don't know if one
inch is all that much of a difference
but it definitely means something and uh
age Andrea's 20 and the Dina is uh 28.
uh so uh that's uh that's uh basically
it ended this is uh uh this is the setup
of basically first uh you you have the
chest and then after they finish the
chest they go into the boxing you can
see that they have headphones I don't
know if they are noise canceling
headphones or maybe I doubt that they
are receiving any information from their
coaches that would be just weird so I'm
pretty sure they're just uh noise
canceling headphones and it's
interesting that uh first move as you
can see that Andrea played with Pawn to
D4 and here Dina already paused a little
bit because she knows that as two of
them have played before uh Dina is a
much stronger player I I believe she
said that she's some 500 rating points
higher rated uh but she knew that Andrea
was going to go for the London system
which uh it's hard to exploit with black
at uh just beat her really quickly but
okay Dina knows that she is a stronger
chess player and she has been training
for for the boxing event as well but as
she said she was only invited like less
than a month before the actual event so
there wasn't all that much time to
prepare uh where Andrea has been in Into
Fitness her entire life as she also
stated so it's uh you know uh uh dean of
course will try to finish it off in the
uh in the in the chess section and
Andrea will have the hope for a knockout
or or maybe just a stoppage of the fight
in the in the boxing section so let's
check it out it's quite uh quite an
interesting game Andrea with the white
pieces opens with the D4 as you've seen
Knight to F6 we have Bishop to F4 going
for the London system setup D6 and now
E3 the London system is here and now
there are many moves black can play here
but here we have Pawn to H6 it's a move
that hasn't been played before so
already as of move three we have a
completely new game and it's something
that Dean obviously wants to take
advantage of she doesn't want the
Android to have a solid position in
chess where she just does nothing and
waits to win in boxing she wants to uh
create Madness on the board and
Checkmate her as soon as possible so
okay Knight to F3 uh Pawn to G5 already
Bishop to G3 with Bishop to G7 and now
Bishop to D3 and Knight the H5 sort of a
uh not the way you would usually play
because it moves the same piece you
already played with in the opening but
it creates uh positions that Andrea
probably never had on the board before
Knight beta D2 and now Knight to C6 with
Ponto C3 this is again just a normal a
London system setup Ponte E6 and pawn to
E4 now very nicely played grabbing the
full Center uh Knight to F4 now and this
Knight is now a menace here threatening
to pick up the bishop on D3 and uh
although you don't want to capture this
it's definitely better than leaving the
Knight on F4 so Bishop captures an F4 G
captures and here Queen to E2 nicely
developing the Queen Bishop to D7 and
here comes Ponte A4 and here there were
six seconds left in the chest section
before they turned to boxing uh we have
Pawn to A5 and now Knight the C4 and
here Queen to E7 and this is the first
30 moves of the chest section and now
they went into 90 minutes of boxing so
as they they said the headphones come uh
come off the gloves come on and um uh
the the the the the the boxing match
started so if you guys want like I
really suggested do watch it on a lot of
his channel as I I don't really watch
Boxing I watch some MMA but um I can't
really comment on the boxing but to me
it seemed like uh Dina was uh mostly uh
mostly waiting and uh looking for that
opportunity to throw like a big punch
whereas Andrea was just poking around
all the time she was like like a like
like a stinger like a bee stinger she
was like just poking her and then uh
when she got tired of receiving those
pokes then she opened up for for a big
hit from from Andrea that's how that's
how I saw it ended the first win was
definitely going to the the first uh
round of boxing uh definitely went to
Andrea uh she uh put in a lot more
energy like she was jumping around all
the time it was uh it was uh well it was
obvious the cheat uh she had a lot more
stamina but okay then the the boxing
event uh or rather the the first round
of boxing ended and then they returned
to the chess and here uh Andrea Andrea's
position is objectively better she could
uh Castle here if she could go upon to
E5 but she goes Queen to D2 she just
puts pressure on this F4 Pawn which
isn't all that impressive as uh well uh
black wants to attack on the king side
it doesn't really make sense to allow
black to open up a more more past the
path path towards the white king um uh
unnecessarily so here Ponte D5 Knight to
A3 and now D captures on e4 with Bishop
captures on e4 and now Ponte F5
attacking the bishop Bishop to C2 and
now just Pawn to E5 this is how uh the
pawn is defended but uh this is an
attacking move uh so the pawn can be
captured the white king is still in the
center of the board so you should
definitely Castle here and you will be
fine but here we have Pawn to D5 by
Andrea and now Pawn to E4 uh saying that
if you capture on C6 it's gonna be uh
big trouble because if d c captures on
C6 then he captures an F3 opens up a
discover to check King to F1 now F
characters on G2 with check King
captures Bishop captures and C6 with
check and after a move like F2 3 which
already you don't want to see on the
board Rook to d8 attacking the White
Queen and now after Queen captures an F4
finally grabbing that Ponder's Bishop to
E5 and that's just uh that's just the
end of the game for the white King The
Rook can come to D2 the queen can come
to H4 Rook can come to G8 uh there's
just no hiding so instead after E4
Andrea just castles and here uh we have
a knight to E5 and Dina played this uh
incredibly quickly uh some of the
commentators thought that she probably
should have captured the Knight but that
would be a mistake because if he
captures an F3 then Andrea is completely
winning D Caprice and C6 Bishop captures
and now Rook F to E1 of course you don't
lose the queen you can block with either
a bishop but let's say a bishop T4 then
Bishop captures F captures uh and now
Queen captures an F4 threatening Rook
captures here so finally Queen side
castles and now Rook captures on e4 will
either both of the pawns immediately or
after a few moves for example Queen F6
you're going to trade Queens captures
captures G3 and now white is up a pawn
but you're gonna win the other Pawn as
well and then being off two pawns it's
gonna be completely winning for Andrea
but okay after Castle's Knight to the E5
this is the absolute strongest move for
Dina and uh it's not easy to defend now
with white knight the D4 of course not
allowing any in any unnecessary trades
and now Pawn to F3 and here uh Andrea
probably knows that capturing is is a
must because if you play G3 then you
just open up I mean uh too much space
here it's very easy to checkmated the
white king also the Knight can come to
G4 you can put pressure on the H2 Pawn
but I think uh she wanted to survive as
as long as possible uh to get a chance
at another boxing round and here if you
play G3 there was five more seconds
until boxing Ponte H5 uh and now we have
Knight 8 to B5 going after the C7 Pawn
this is move 22 and here another
stoppage of the of the chest and again
the gloves come on uh so so boxing
boxing starts and Andrea has much less
time on the clock in chess she has two
minutes on the clock Dina has uh more
than four minutes on on the clock and uh
Andrea should really look at the
finisher the uh the match during the
boxing round because if this continues
she will probably get the checkmated and
it was uh it was uh it was a it was a
pretty much the repetition of round one
of the boxing uh Andrea again went all
out with her uh Stinger punches and she
even
um uh got the referee to intervene uh
the referee started counting if Dina
could continue the fight uh he got like
the maybe six or seven seconds and then
Dina said she could continue and she
basically survived the the chess section
of the of the fight and then the third
part of the of the chess match continued
uh and here you could just easily castle
and protect the C7 Pawn but Dina just
played the story after Knight a to B5 uh
Dina played Bishop to H6 going after the
White Queen here Queen to D1 and now
Queen to G5 now that you can play Queen
to G5 as the wife Queen was guarding
that but now getting rid of the queen
now Checkmate is coming queen G4 Queen
H3 and then either Checkmate or if you
stop that Knight to G4 followed by Queen
captures an H2 Checkmate uh the the
problem for for Dina is that um uh
there's uh two minutes of Chess and
Andrea has like two minutes and six
seconds on the clock so if if Andrea
wants she can just let the entire time
uh run out on on her chest clock uh uh
on on the chest section clock and she
will still have six seconds left on the
clock to go for one more round of boxing
before uh she she succumbs to Checkmate
so here at Knight captures and C7 check
was played and now King to F7 you have
to be very careful here if Dina goes
King to fade then just Knight the E6
check will win the black queen it
captures captures again you lose the
black queen so after Knight captures on
C7 King the F7 was played again the the
strongest move the only good move for
black and now King the H1 Andrea knows
that once the queen comes to H3 you have
to put the Rook on G1 to stop Checkmate
but again the Knight is coming to G4 and
both checkmates uh uh who will be
[Applause]
um uh available to Black so here Queen
to G4 and now Pawn to D6 and here okay
white is making some progress but it's
actually a forced Checkmate in eight for
Dina and he goes she goes for Queen to
H3 we have Bishop to B3 with check King
to G6 and now Rook to G1 stopping
Checkmate Knight the G4 and now comes
Knight E captures on F3 as now uh trying
to give back some pieces and here you
can see just how shook the players were
uh Dina actually has a mate in one
Knight captures on F2 is Checkmate in
one but she went for the automatic
capture with Knight captures on F3 she
played e captures on F3 and now Bishop
to F7 check Andrea just playing moves uh
and not allowing herself to get
checkmated to survive to one more round
of boxing here King the H7 by Dina now
whatever Andrea does it's checkmating
too but this is where the time of of the
chest ran out and now again she has 90
seconds
um a minute and a half of boxing to
knock out the Dina in order to win the
match and it was it was quite brutal the
the the the those 90 seconds were so
brutal like the the first two rounds uh
Andrea went all out with her Stinger
punches and now in round three she
continued with the Stinger punches
throwing out so much energy Dina was
just uh she was basically running around
the ring avoiding those those punches
and the referee had to intervene twice
and I think uh Dina knew this because if
the referee interwe interweens uh three
times then the match is over but she
allowed the referee to intervene uh two
times and every time she waited for him
to count to those eight seconds uh you
can't reach tend to see if she was all
right to continue the match and I think
she was maybe doing that on purpose to
win more time just to survive uh the
boxing part and then to get back to
chess because she she knows she has
Checkmate in too and she was able to
survive it there was no third stoppage
and uh even though she was really
getting knocked around uh she managed to
survive the the the the boxing part and
return to the board here once they
continued the the chess Andrea played
Bishop to G6 check D not captured then
G6 and he was in this position uh
unmoved 31 that Andrea both has resigned
in the game as there is nothing more to
be done here uh whatever you do it's
Checkmate in one Queen captures on H2
will be Checkmate and there is no way
uh to solve this even if you try
something like Rook here again Queen to
G2 will be Checkmate so it was a really
really an incredible fight
um uh uh here uh I mean uh like I said
Dina knew that she was the stronger
chess player being 500 rating points
higher rated but she thought that this
was a good opportunity for her to get uh
into the best shape of her life and try
to try to do something in the boxing
section uh but she was unable to do that
like if the if uh if the referee did not
stop the fights as as much as he did it
would be I mean it would be a massacre
but that's why this is not chess this is
not boxing this is chess boxing and you
have to uh utilize both of those in
order to emerge Victorious which Andrea
also did actually didn't allow herself
to get checkmated she just waited for
the time to run out in order to continue
boxing where she is better and that's
pretty much what Dina did basically what
the Dina did she was playing chess
during both chess and boxing and in the
end emerged emerged Victorious and
Andrea was not happy with this she after
the match the uh the the commentator
asked her to give a give a comment on
the match and everything and she said
that she thought this was a chess match
and that it felt more like playing
um uh hide and seek but yeah it's uh All
In All I Do I Do suggest you watching a
Ludwig's Channel really uh definitely I
haven't seen all the fights yet I will
check him out but this does appear to be
the the the the fight of the of the
entire event uh so yeah that's the game
and the match hope you guys enjoyed that
sorry about the poor commentary unboxing
as I'm not uh really an expert or you
know I'm not I'm nothing when it comes
to boxing so I can't really offer any
insight on that but do check it out you
you will you will enjoy it uh so yeah
once again really hope you enjoyed this
I would like to thank Lucia basic
Croatia Nikola pokrovsky dervin the
Hagler and PG master for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here and thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing uh to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day